2024 as old conflicts rumble on and new
threats emerge one image more than any
other will be replicated around the
globe in a year that we'll see the
biggest display of democracy in history
what else will the next 12 months bring
here are some of the stories set to
shape the world
ahead
[Music]
2024 will be the biggest election year
in history more than half of the world's
population live in countries holding
national elections but there are two
elections in particular that could have
huge repercussions
worldwide one is the most powerful
democracy in the world the other is a
small self-governing island less than
200 km off the coast of China
the election in Taiwan in January
matters because the Island's future is
so uncertain according to us
intelligence president SI jingping wants
his Armed Forces to be ready for an
invasion by 2027 Taiwan is a
geopolitical flasho an invasion by China
could lead to war with America so the
stakes are high for whoever wins power
in both Taiwan and America the strategy
they pursue could deter Chinese Invasion
or hasten
it on the island itself the threat for
some is already tangible more than half
of Taiwanese citizens do not have
confidence in their government's ability
to defend against an Invasion From
China some citizens are even taking
civil defense workshops including
22-year-old chenbo yen
[Music]
for and those concerns will be at the
Forefront of Taiwanese voters Minds when
they head to the polls in
January voters will be faced with a
choice between the current ruling party
which emphasizes Taiwanese self-rule and
the need to resist Chinese
bullying and two opposition parties Keen
to pursue warmer
relations supporters of the current
government claim the opposition would
make it easier for China to ultimately
take over
Taiwan and on the other hand the
opposition came think that the DP
government is going to take Taiwan to
the P of legal
Independence and that will be a pass to
a eventual war with China the likelihood
Ood of War won't just depend on what
happens in taiwan's election but in
America's too would you send the US
military into Taiwan if president shei
were to invade President Biden say I
won't say I won't say a second Trump
presidency would spell unpredictability
and mounting levels of risk and not just
for Taiwan but for America and the rest
of the
world
[Music]
in July all eyes will be on Paris for
the 2024 Olympic games but while
athletes battle it out on the ground
Spectators eyes might be drawn to the
skies above at first glance it might be
mistaken for a helicopter but this is a
super siiz drone and it could be the
future of public transport known as as
Evol electric vertical takeoff and
Landing they run entirely on batteries
making them a sustainable way to fly 5
years ago evts was only known to a very
small group of people that were really
Aviation geeks tinkering on new
technologies over the last year or so
we've seen a lot of public test flights
and next year commercial service is the
Milestone if all goes to plan the Paris
Olympics will Mark the start of
commercial EPO flights while helicopter
the company running the flights is
hoping to transport tourists along five
different routes at speeds of up to 110
km hour we believe if we can fly in
Paris we can fly anywhere this is also a
start into a new area of Mobility
allowing quiet safe and sustainable
vehicles to enter the city centers which
other vehicles can't the technology is
evolving so rapidly that Aviation
Regulators are struggling to work out
how to certify flights
volocopter has had to roll back on its
original plan of pilotless self-flying
Eevee TOS to try to appease the
authorities I think the only way to get
certified right now and for the years to
come is by offering a piloted version uh
it's not technology that hinders us to
go towards autonomy it is certification
and public acceptance volocopter is not
the only company hoping to take off in
2024 across the world other companies
are racing to the skies in a market that
could be worth $1 trillion by
2040 but while much of the industry will
be commercial some companies will be
catering for those who prefer to go
private we've got two large Wings you're
getting all your lift from in 2024 Palo
AO startup pivotal will be launching an
EV to anyone with deep enough Pockets
can purchase and pilot themselves with
just one seat it's more of a flying
motorbike than a flying taxi it's a
feeling it's pretty hard to describe uh
to see the world from up there the
company provides a few weeks of training
but you don't need a pilot's license as
long as it's only flown over rural land
and during daylight the Helix will be
one of the most easy tolearn to fly
vehicles ever made you need to use a
single joystick to do everything the
aircraft can do from takeoff to Landing
to hover to forward flight although with
a price tag of
$190,000 they're not cheap there is no
denying that it's going to be used
principally for recreation to start but
it will grow from there and it will
become a new form of transportation that
we take for granted
[Music]
Someday I'm Tom stage editor of the
world ahead to read about the prospects
for the coming year and get a head start
on more of the trends and themes to
watch why not take out a subscri destion
to The Economist which includes full
access to the world ahead 2024 to get
the best offer click on the
[Music]
link in 2024 the focus on AI won't just
be on what it can do but how humans
might control it some people are worried
that if you impose strict rules too
early you stifle the technology and
other people are worried that if you
don't move now then there could be
Danger
consequences so far much of the
discussion around regulation has been on
the most powerful AI known as Frontier
models and the risks they could pose to
humanity but there's a danger that
decision makers are looking the wrong
way we should be focusing on the real
immediate potential but also the real
immediate risks of this technology which
aren't about Killer Robots they're about
things like bias and discrimination many
governments are less than transparent
about how they deploy AI in
decision-making
in London the charity the public law
project has been trying to uncover how
the British government is using
algorithms so we can see 28 tools that
are currently being used by the home
office one of their projects examines
the British government's use of machine
learning a form of AI in its
investigation of Welfare fraud people
who were applying for welfare support
all of the same nationality background
they were having their benefits
suspended for a really long period of
time we were really concerned that some
of these systems might be operating in a
way that's discriminatory there's
precedent for this in 2021 an AI welfare
Scandal brought down the Dutch
government the tech service here in the
Netherlands was wrongfully accusing tens
of thousands of families that they were
frauding with child
benefits and Australia's Robo debt
scandal led to at least two suicides
driven to despair by a soulless
automated debt collector and a
government who called them willare
cheets there has been some movement in
an attempt to mitigate near-term risks
the EU is expected to bring in its AI
act in
2024 there will also be two AI safety
Summits one in South Korea and one in
Paris but if there are anything like the
first safety Summit AT Bletchley Park in
2023 their focus will be mostly on
Frontier models and existential risk I
think talking up these existential
theoretical future risks is really just
a way of hyping the technology overall
Elon Musk would like to sell you a
self-driving car that uses AI to drive
itself but he also says that AI is
really really dangerous if we are not
careful with creating artificial general
intelligence we could have potentially a
catastrophic outcome some people go as
far as to say that this is actually a
Del iate sort of decoy trying to
distract attention from the real
existing harms of AI systems and it's
also a way of drawing attention for the
people who work in the fields to just
how powerful and and wonderful they are
they're really saying I made this thing
that could destroy the world aren't I
[Music]
clever in 2024 one of the world's
overlooked greenhouse gas emitters will
finally be in the
spotlight
until now government's Focus has been on
cleaning up the most visible polluters
like energy and transport but in the
coming year attention will turn towards
industry and the production of materials
Central to Modern everyday life industry
is often out of sight unlike the cars we
drive or the electricity that powers our
homes but in fact almost everything that
we need in our lives is made by
industry factories and other industrial
facilities belt out vast amounts of
greenhouse
gases nearly 29% of all emissions that's
the same amount as electricity
generation and almost double
transport a big part of the problem is
that some industrial processes need high
temperatures which at the moment rely on
fossil fuels like coal and natural
gas that's been a real challenge but
that's also turning into a real
opportunity for some innovators
coolbrook is a finished startup
developing technology it thinks can
bring the world one step closer to Green
industry their rotodynamic heater
generates high temperatures using
electricity is really the heart and Z of
the installation the gas goes around the
donut multiple times and then exits from
the other side which means with the use
of renewable electricity it can power
industry with entirely sustainable
energy what we want to do is that we
replace majority of of fossile fuels in
industry and that is very much
doable after Decades of development 2024
is the Year this technology will start
being shipped to factories it's
absolutely exciting time the last 10
years have been already the time of
intensive development and last two to
three years have really been the
GameChanger for us what we have now seen
is that the heavy industry is really
starting to
move industry might be more willing to
decarbonize because of incoming
regulation in 2023 the European Union
introduced a carbon tax on Imports we'll
see how it actually plays out in
2024 we're likely to see other big
economies the United States the UK and
Australia come up with their own
versions of their carbon
tax and this kind of Regulation has
spurred the creation of other
decarbonizing
Technologies a few startups have come up
with new ways of containing renewable
energy in sometimes what are called
rocks in a box that are small packages
that get very hot retain the Heat and
can release it on demand when a factory
needs it but industry can sometimes drag
its feet and questions remain about
whether it can change fast enough one of
the obstacles to decarbonizing heavy
industry is that the processes are very
complicated it can be expensive and
involve investment in New Capital
Equipment which industry does not want
to do factory bosses don't like to shut
down their factories and replace the kit
that they use uh because of the dreams
of
environmentalists it's a bit like
changing the wheels on a bus while the
bus is moving at full speed but that's
kind of what we have to
[Music]
do in 2024 the American Le World Order
is going to be challenged again as a
block of non-western Nations gets bigger
the bricks made up of Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa will add
five new members individually the bricks
are some of the most exciting and
biggest economies on the planet China is
the world's second biggest economy India
is growing rapidly in 2024 the club of
five will be joined by Egypt Ethiopia
Iran Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates Argentina was also slated to
join but that now looks unlikely under
its new president Javier M on paper
bricks plus seems a formidable outfit
together its members account for nearly
half of the world's population and their
share of GDP is around 20% more than the
G7 a group of Rich democracies Allied to
America but in reality their power will
depend on how well they get on they
don't seem to have that much in common
they're very very different economies
India is on a huge kick about green
minerals China seems to be driving its
economy towards consumption rather than
investment what's more there have been
recent skirmishes between China's and
India's armies across their shared
border there's also a chance that would
have found out that the bricks mean very
little other than a club for people to
discuss things but what's really
interesting about all these countries
that are joining next year is that
they're the countries that have had some
of the most strained relations with the
west and its Financial order this Global
Financial system was created in the
ashes of the second world war at Breton
Woods 44 Nations gathered to establish a
new international monetary and financial
order with America at the helm What's
significant about the expansion of
bricks is that it challenges this
American Le world order the most
important thing about the bricks has
always been that America isn't invited
and there are ways in which the bricks
are using that American dominated
Financial system and trying to twist it
to their own Advantage the bricks have
created their own alternative to the
World Bank and their own currency swap
lines in which countries agree to swap
different currencies cantering the
influence of the IMF and its currency of
choice the
dollar and it's not just America's
global economic influence that is being
challenged by the rise of middle Powers
the world is changing and America's
influence is declining America is also a
security power and its military is far
super to any other countries in the
world but increasingly there are several
smaller rich countries that are playing
the role of the world's negotiator in
the war in Ukraine much of the mediation
has been done by
turkey and in the war in Gaza by
Qatar America's power is unlikely to be
eclipsed anytime soon its network of
allies is still much bigger than China's
but in
2024 expect the world to be become more
multi-polar as middle Powers Flex their
muscles thanks for watching to read more
of our coverage of the coming year click
the link and don't forget to
subscribe